da habe ich megawatt
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich freue mich
sehr weil dieses video wird ein sehr
geiles video es geht nämlich endlich mal
wieder im autos und zwar um mein neues
auto das wir ja im laufe des videos
abholen werden
ich fahre jetzt für heute sonntag fahre
ich nach münchen gerade halb neun
ich werde mitgenommen netterweise was
passt wir uns gut dann machen auch einen
tag was den menschen besuchten freund
und morgen früh hole ich dann mein neues
auto wahrscheinlich schon im titel oder
es wird ein bmw
ich freue mich dass es geklappt hat und
ja ich habe das auto noch nicht einmal
in echt gesehen morgen ist das erste mal
aber wir schon geil ich wünsche euch
viel spaß mit dass walker länger nicht
und sehr gern im kanalnetz
[Musik]
so hatte
nein
so leute ich bin mittlerweile schon in
münchen angekommen
bei christian mir hallo ja ja und die
übergabe ist leider erst morgen also wir
bringen jetzt auch einen netten tag hier
in münchen und leute und außer dass wir
hier getrunken haben noch ein bier
getrunken haben und noch ein schnitzel
gegessen haben habe ich eigentlich in
münchen nicht so viel gefilmt eigentlich
voll schade tut mir leid aber egal dann
war auch schon der nächste tag und ich
konnte endlich das auto abholen
vielleicht was wir morgen ich habe jetzt
gerade über bestellt mit dem nichts zu
bewegen eigentlich ein käufer print also
aus gesehen weil ich dachte es war ein
bisschen später das was ich jetzt
geradezu nach vorne gezogen und den sehe
ich aus als hätte ich eine steckdose im
griff
naja gefahrlos ich freue mich mehr geht
immer schief und wünschen
so klappt klappt schon ich habe immer
bei allem was um autos geht habe ich
schon bei jedem so meine bedenken
letztere sind jetzt das waren jetzt
wahrscheinlich richtig sogar dankeschön
so leute das sieht doch ganz gut aus
angekommen ist ruhig mal irgendwie mal
ein ansprechpartner
so leute ich fühle was jetzt gerade beim
handy ab da kommt schon meine jungs und
ein toller die haben wir schon die 8 in
mini allerdings gefällt mir die farbe
nicht so muss ich sagen glaube meine hat
wenn ich glück habe eine andere farbe
das übrigens die beiden jungs von
leasing fuchs stelle ich euch leider vor
die sind auch netterweise aber irgend
morgen wird es tatsächlich schon einmal
zum auto gehen und ich guck mal das
waren also was ist jetzt meine erste
reaktion darauf machte gleich noch mal
ein kleines fazit ich finden wir uns
hinterfragen so leute ich sitze jetzt
schon im neuen auto drin
wir haben uns jetzt dafür entschieden
ich fahre jetzt gleich erstmal hier raus
und dann machen wir draußen ein paar
aufnahmen und zeigen euch denn auch mal
ich denke mal dass es draußen noch viel
besser vom licht her
ich bin auf jeden fall da ich weiß gar
nicht was ich sagen soll also ich freue
mich extrem und so ganz realisieren kann
man das noch nicht mehr weit ist es
einfach also das ist ein absolutes
traumauto und ich freue mich so
unendlich goldin jetzt zu fahren halt
jeden tag ja also wir sehen uns
vielleicht draußen ich weiß gar nicht
mehr sagen
bis gleich
vor
die
[Musik]
leute also das ist jetzt ein bisschen
mehr kraft noch das ist jetzt
tatsächlich mein neues auto ich bin ja
schon mal vorm jahr oder so probe
gefahren da kann ich den so geil dass
ich den unbedingt haben wollte und das
hat jetzt glücklicherweise geklappt ich
bin auch sehr happy weil so viele gibt's
davon gar nicht mehr die werden ja nicht
mehr gebracht und den habe ich jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal ein paar jahre
ich freue mich sehr über wir haben den
laden abgeholt und sind jetzt direkt
hier genau hier vor der allianz arena
obwohl ich ja eigentlich dortmund fan
bin
aber egal ich bin ja so gut zur zeit da
kann man dann auch für die leute die
nicht wissen was das ist ist ein bmw i8
coupé aber ich will da gar nicht zuviel
zu sagen umsetzung das gleich noch ein
paar mal eine runde und ich muss vor
allem heute auch wir sind wir gerade in
münchen ich komme ja aus nrw hat geht es
heute auf jeden fall noch einige hundert
kilometer wieder nach hause und ich habe
hinter der kamera noch dennis und das
denn von leasing fuchs ihm da ein
bisschen zur seite gestanden haben und
alles da für mich übernommen haben und
wie zeige ich euch jetzt vielleicht auch
mal und dann besprechen wir noch ein
bisschen was im auto also komm wir gehen
so leute was geht ab ich muss sagen ich
bin schon wieder zu hause und zwar habe
ich mich dazu entschieden jetzt hier
nochmal in ruhe das video zu drehen oder
zumindest diesen teil des videos beim
autohaus warst du mich so ein bisschen
hektisch und die aufgaben sind halt
einfach nicht so cool geworden auch
wegen der maske und so man hat mich
eigentlich gar nicht verstanden und
deswegen dachte ich mir jetzt setzte
sich hier schön macht uns auto wenn die
sonne untergeht und balazs man ein
bisschen also nein
jetzt nicht zu schnell aber einmal hier
auch drauf drücken euch das zu zeigen
was das auto dann so hergibt so richtig
mal direkt hier im sportmodus
war ja
entschuldigung also ich glaube ich hab's
ja schon gesagt dann steht ja im titel
das ist ein bmw i8 coupé von ist der
elektromotor hinten der verbrenner also
wir haben vorne sorgen für 130 ps und
hinten noch mal 240 und wenn man dann
halt im sport modus ein kleid dann geht
ja auch wirklich also das kind nach
vorne nicht frei hast halt also für mich
ist es das beste was ich je gefahren
habe und deswegen macht es mir unfassbar
viel spaß und ich bin so glücklich dass
ich denn jetzt einfach habe
[Musik]
nein
es macht spaß ich bin eigentlich gar
nicht der typ ja so drauf drückt und
immer schnell fährt aber mit dem auch du
bist wirklich und du merkst überhaupt
nicht dass 200 bist du denkst du fährst
140 und was sich sehr fair
der verbrauch von dem auto ist ziemlich
gering ach so ja leute wir sind jetzt
gerade noch mal auf dem parkplatz gedüst
und zwar würde ich euch ganz gerne jetzt
nochmal hier den dennis und das team
vorstellen
die haben wir bei der ganzen sache
nämlich ziemlich unter die arme
gegriffen und mir immer passende
angebote geschickt und ich konnte mir
eigentlich heraussuchen was mir gepasst
hat dann gab es da mehr infos zu und so
ist das dann hier entstand mit dem i8
das ging auch ziemlich schnell muss ich
sagen und vor allem sehr preiswert würde
ich auch manch andere genau deswegen
könnte eine super g power konzept immer
vorstellen und wenn von euch da draußen
irgend wer interesse hat an sowas glaube
da seid ihr auf jeden fall nicht an der
falschen adresse wenn ihr euch dann an
die beiden wände kontaktdaten instagram
oder so verlinkt ich auf jeden fall mal
hier dann könnt ihr da mal vorbei schon
gepostet ja auch immer so neuer autos
reinkriegt naja also schießt ihr habt
das wort also wir sind die gründer von
leasing fuchs bei uns geht es rund um
das ganze thema leasing
das heißt wenn er auf der suche nach
einem neuen fahrzeug seid dann könnt ihr
euch gerne bei uns melden wir suchen
euch das passende fahrzeug raus von a
bis z also ob es ein lupo ist ein
porsche oder lamborghini sogar da finden
wir immer das passende und wir kümmern
uns im prinzip komplett um das ganze
hintenrum sage ich jetzt mal ich bin ich
um die formalitäten verträge hin und
herschicken das machen wir im prinzip
alles und ich musste am ende gar nix
machen genau rathenower vertrag
unterschreiben erholen aber der kunde
hat nichts mit den formalitäten zu tun
da kümmern wir uns im hintergrund traum
der kunde muss nur noch unterschreiben
und fahrzeug abholen oder halt liefern
lassen es auch möglich ja genau genau
ich glaube das war ganz gut erklären was
ich noch sagen wollte der verbrauch von
autos auch merck einen spannenden zeit
bis 55 km/h meine ich oder 60 km h
elektrisch fahren und dann schaltet sich
erst der verbrenner dazu es sei denn du
willst direkt losballern und schaltet
das herum
auf jeden fall ging das echt klar ich
glaube ich hab einmal voll getankten bin
von wünschen bisschen hingekommen
ungefähr 600 zehn kilometer der
elektromotor war auch voll aufgeladen
wer ist jetzt gerade nur bei zwei
kilometern jetzt ab werk
[Musik]
die geister
wir müssen schon wieder runter was
vergessen hat man muss dazu sagen
der sound ist halt nicht mehr dabei ist
doch mit was ihr könnt euch hoffentlich
auch viele weitere coole videos mit dem
i8 freuen
da hab ich mir kaufen
[Musik]
hey leute ich glaube das war jetzt genug
das video ist jetzt eigentlich am ende
als ich wollte das nur noch zu sagen
danke fürs zuschauen eine sache die ich
vielleicht noch sagen wollte weil ich
weiß dass das immer in den kommentaren
aufkommen bei meinem letzten auch schon
so und zwar die ganzen leute schreiben
ölfilm gelegt ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen wenn ich mir so ein tolles auto
kaufen würde also das wäre an sich schon
zu treffen ich könnte mir das vielleicht
schon länger sehr hell vielleicht ein
bisschen dumm so viel geld dafür
auszugeben deswegen für meine
gewerblichen tätigkeiten bietet sich
dieses leasing immer super anderen das
neue möglichkeit für mich sollte ich
vielleicht mal kurz dazu gesagt haben
jetzt 400 bist du schon ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen ich habe echt jetzt schon
ein bisschen öl ins video gesteckt und
wir sind uns dann am wochenende wieder
rein